clear how the united states would
respond
predicted they would invade and they
surely did
we said we not send u.s troops to fight
russian troops in ukraine but we would
provide
robust military assistance and try to
unify the western world against russia's
aggression
i said i would impose powerful sanctions
on russia and that we destroy and
develop we destroy
this myth that somehow they can continue
to move without the rest of the world
acting
that we deploy additional forces to
defend nato territory particularly in
the east along the russian and belarus
borders
that's exactly that's exactly what we
said we would do and we did but despite
the disturbing rhetoric coming out of
the kremlin the facts are plain for
everybody to see
we're not attacking russia we're helping
ukraine defend itself against russian
aggression
and just as putin chose to launch this
brutal invasion
he could make the choice to end this
brutal invasion
russia is the aggressor no if ends or
buts about it russia is the aggressor
and the world must and will hold russian
accountable
russia continues assault on as yielding
immense human cost
we've seen
we've seen them leave behind horrifying
evidence of their atrocities and war
crimes and the areas they try to control
and as long as the assaults and
atrocities continue we're going to
continue to supply military systems i
might know parenthetically
you know there's a dinner this weekend
uh celebrate the press
think of what the american press has
done
the courage is taken
to stay in these war zones the courage
has taken the report every single day
i've always had respect for the press
but i can't tell you how much respect i
have watching
watching them in these zones where
they're under fire risking their own
lives to make sure the world hears the
truth
imagine if we weren't getting that
information
it'd be a different world it'd be a
different circumstance
in the past two months russia launched
this brutal attack has moved weapons and
equipment to ukraine we've moved we've
moved weapons and equipment and to
ukraine in record speed
thanks to the aid we provided russian
forces have been forced to retreat from
kiev doesn't mean they're not going to
try to come back but they've retreated
thus far
we've sent thousands of anti-armor
anti-missiles helicopters drones grenade
launchers machine guns rifles radar
systems
more than 50 million rounds of
ammunition
the united states alone has provided 10
anti-armor systems for every russian
tank that is in ukraine ten to one
providing ukraine significant timely
intelligence to help them defend
themselves against the russian onslaught
and we're facilitating a significant
flow of weapons and systems to ukraine
from our allies and partners around the
world including tanks artillery and
other weapons
that support is moving with
unprecedented speed
much much of the new equipment we've
announced
in the past two months two weeks has
already gotten to ukraine where it can
be put to direct use on the battlefield
however
we've almost exhausted what we call the
fancy phrase the drawdown authority that
congress authorized ukraine for
authorized ukraine in a bipartisan
spending bill last month basically we're
out of money
and so that's why today in order to
sustain
ukraine as a as it continues to fight
i'm sending congress a supplemental
budget request
it's going to keep weapons and
ammunition flowing without interruption
to the brave ukrainian fighters and
continue delivering economic and
humanitarian assistance to the ukrainian
people
this so-called supplemental funding
addresses the needs of the ukrainian
military during the critical weeks and
months ahead
and it begins and begins to transition
to term security systems that's going to
help ukraine deter and continue to
defend against russian aggression
this assistance would provide even more
artillery
armored vehicles anti-armored systems
anti-air capabilities
that have been used so effectively thus
far in the battlefield by the ukrainian
warriors
you know it's going to deliver
much-needed humanitarian assistance as
well as food water medicine shelter and
other aid to ukrainians displaced by
russia's war and provide aid for those
seeking refuge in other countries from
ukraine
it's also going to help schools and
hospitals open
it's going to allow pensions and social
support to be paid to the ukrainian
people so they have something something
in their pocket
it's also going to provide critical
resources to address food shortages
around the globe
ukraine
ukraine was one of the world's largest
agricultural producers
it typically grows 10 percent of all the
wheat that's shipped around the world
putin
has asserted sanctions are blocking food
from ukraine and russia getting on the
market the sanctions we've imposed on
russia simply not true
putin's war not sanctions
are impacting the harvest of food and
disrupting the movement
of that food by land and sea to nations
around the globe that need it
this fund is going to help ease rising
food prices at home as well and abroad
caused by russia's war in ukraine it's
going to help support american farmers
produce more crops like wheat and oil
seed which is good for rural america
good for the american consumer and good
for the world
and this supplemental request will use
the defense production act to expand
domestic production
and reserve and the reserve of critical
materials
materials like nickel and lithium that
have been disrupted by putin's war in
ukraine and that are necessary to make
everything from defense systems to
automobiles
and i hope congress i hope congress will
move on this funding quickly i believe
they will
i want to thank congress democrats and
republicans for the support of people of
ukraine
and next week i will be in alabama
to visit lockheed martin plant that
manufactures the javelin anti-tank
missile we've been sending to ukraine
and to thank the american workers
thank them for producing the weapons
that helped stop russia's advances in
ukrainian cities like key
their hard work has played a critical
role in ensuring putin's strategic
failure in ukraine and they should know
that we know it
in addition to this supplemental funding
i'm also sending to congress a
comprehensive package
of that will enhance our underlying
effort to accommodate the russian
oligarchs uh and make sure we take their
take their their ill-begotten gains
we're going to accommodate them
we're going to seize their yachts their
luxury homes and other ill-begotten
gains
of putin's kleptocrats
yeah
kleptocracy and clip the guys who are
the kleptocracies
but these are bad guys
this legislative package strengthens our
law enforcement capabilities to seize
property linked to russia's kleptocracy
it's going to create new expedited
procedures
for forfeiture and seizure of these
these properties and it's going to
ensure that when the oligarchs assets
are sold off
funds can be used directly to remedy the
harm russia caused in their help and
helped build ukraine
additionally yesterday
russia threatened two of our allies with
a cutoff of energy supplies
while america has ended all russian
fossil fuel imports because we're able
to use our vast support supply of power
in our country
some european countries have faced more
challenges in reducing the reliance on
russian fuel
russia has long claimed to be quote the
reliable source of energy for the world
no matter what the differences are their
customers are always going to be
being in good shape
but these actions prove that energy is
not just a commodity that russia sells
to help meet other countries needs but a
weapon
will use to deploy against those who
stand against their aggression
let me be clear
we will not let russia intimidate or
blackmail their way out of these
sanctions
we will not allow them to use their oil
and gas to avoid consequences for their
aggression
we're working with other nations like
korea japan qatar and others to support
our effort to help european allies
threatened by russia with gas blackmail
and their energy needs in other ways
aggression
will not win
threats will not win
this is just another reminder
of the imperative for europe and the
world to move more and more of our power
needs to clean energy
in the united states
we're doing that right now
last year we developed more solar wind
and battery storage than any year in our
history
enough to power 56 million american
homes
earlier this month we acted to bolster
the are reliant the reliance on our
nuclear energy facilities which
generates more than half of our
carbon-free power
and we're just getting started
i look at this as a serious problem but
also an enormous opportunity
an opportunity
bottom line
all these actions we've been taking
are about the truth this truth investing
in ukraine's freedom and security
is a small price to pay to punish russia
and aggression to lessen the risk for
future conflicts
you know throughout our history we've
learned that when dictators do not pay
the price for their aggression they
cause more chaos and engage in more
aggression
they keep moving and the cost
the threats to america
and the world keep rising we can't let
this happen
our unity at home
our unity with our allies and partners
and our unity with the ukrainian people
is sending an unmistakable message to
putin
you will never succeed in dominating
ukraine
finally
we're going to continue to deliver
critical support to ukraine
we must also not let our guard down in
our fight against covet 19 at home and
abroad
that's why i'm again urging congress to
act on my request
for 22.5 billion dollars in emergency
resources so the american people can
continue to protect themselves from kobe
19.
the reason we were so successful in the
past
is because i was able to work with drug
manufacturers to order significant
quantities of material we needed ahead
of time to get in the front of the line
without additional funding we can't
pre-order the amount of vaccines we need
and we risk losing our spot in line for
vaccines that target multiple variants
we're running president joe biden there
speaking about uh trying to get
additional funding to send more weapons
and medical aid to
ukraine he had a message for president
putin you will never succeed in
dominating ukraine other nations in the
world combined
if the us won't do it no one else is
really going to step up
breaking news here on sky news and the
british national killed in ukraine has
been named as scott sibley his neck to
next of kin have been informed that
picture there of scott sibley who's just
been named as the
british national killed in ukraine the
foreign office of course confirming to
sky news as well that another british
national is missing in ukraine scott
sibley now named as the british national
killed in ukraine
okay well let's pick up now on uh that
um uh press conference with joe biden
there i'm joined now by our
correspondent david bleson blevins who's
in washington d.c for us um he had a
number of things to say there didn't he
david a lot about the budget that he
needs that to be approved to send that
crucial equipment um but also responding
really to accusations by russia of proxy
wars saying we're not at war with russia
we're simply defending ukraine
yes let's just perhaps start by
summarizing that aid package he's asking
congress to sign off on a staggering 33
billion dollars 20 billion of it for
military aid alone eight and a half for
economic assistance
three billion for humanitarian aid and
500 million for domestic food production
assistance that's because of a global
shortage of crops used for the
production of food that's eaten here in
the united states it's an incredible
amount of money he also wants to impose
further sanctions that's despite the
fact that he's already imposed heavy
sanctions on russian oligarchs the
kleptocracy the word he stumbled over a
little and on president putin's ex-wife
and daughters here and on the wife of
the russian foreign minister what he
wants to do now is impose further
sanctions and ensure that what is
forfeited is used to aid ukraine i think
what really we've learned in the last
few minutes is that the president is
hopeful of bipartisan support for this
aid and and that in itself is a shift
when you consider that just two or three
weeks ago his opponents on the hill were
criticizing him describing him as gaff
prone and risking exacerbating the war
by appearing to suggest russia should
remove president putin from office and
talking about the possibility of u.s
boots on the ground it tells us he's not
deterred by threats from moscow that the
united states will face unpredictable
consequences if it continues to arm
ukraine and i think it also tells us
that they know they're in this for the
long haul since assuming office
president biden has given three billion
dollars of aid to ukraine two billion in
military assistance in the last three
weeks alone the scale of what he's now
asking congress to approve tells us that
he thinks this is going to go on for a
while and it's something he wants to see
tidied up and resolved perhaps so that
he can begin to focus a little more on
the domestic agenda as we approach the
midterms
and david um
about this ramping up of uh rhetoric
between you know nato members and russia
russia very keen to try and put this on
uh some kind of proxy war also
threatening of course that uh that um to
strike outside of ukraine as well
because the british defense secretary
said that ukrainians could strike russia
using western weapons there's a lot of
talk back and forth and and concerns
about this spreading beyond ukraine's
borders
yes and the president i think has been
under pressure continually to
really clearly take the side of ukraine
you'll remember just at the weekend as
the u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken uh traveled to kiev that's
because america had been under pressure
to send a hope a high-profile
representative there following boris
johnson's visit earlier in the month
shortly before they arrived president
zielenski said he hoped the americans
weren't coming with
gifts and with cake is how he described
it but we're coming with news of
specific weapons after the visit of the
secretary of state and the u.s defense
secretary austin
they clearly indicated that they were
supporting ukraine as to the fullest
possible extent and that's what the
president is continuing to say the
message he's continuing to send to
russia that they stand four square
behind
president zielenski regardless of
threats from moscow about consequences
for the united states so the president
is refusing to become part of president
putin's attempt to establish a proxy war
and clearly coming down firmly on the
side of president zielinski and that's
because he clearly now is confident that
he will have bipartisan support from
congress
david blevins live in washington dc
thanks very much indeed
well here in the uk a man charged with
murdering mother of two katie kenyon has
appeared in court andrew burfield gave
no plea indication at blackburn
magistrates court and was remanded in
custody to appear at preston carrance
court tomorrow meanwhile lancashire
police have intensified their search in
gisborne forest gerald tubb is there for
us gerard um describe the scene there
for us will you
so
so since the weekend they've been
searching gisborne forest they know that
the van that they believe that katy
kenyon was taken from burnley in
was here
on friday she disappeared 9 30 friday
morning was seen going into that van
they think she was taken here a member
of the public they've now told us uh
cited that van told them uh they'd seen
it that was clearly in a lay by about
half a mile away from where i am we were
there last night at half past nine and
the fire and rescue were taking lights
into the forest area they had forensic
tents up where they can get changed in
there was a hub of activity there last
night
a dozen police vehicles lining the road
and they were working through the night
today they've gone back there and we've
just been filming forensic teams doing
fingertip searches
perhaps 75 yards in on a path from that
parking area they've taken plaster casts
of tire tracks
in the area where they believe his van
was parked and they've um told us that
that's why they're searching that area
and then they say that they're trying to
determine whether or not it is of
interest and then later on in the brief
release that they've given to us
lancashire police say that it's too
early to know whether the find uh is
significant in relation to katy kenyon's
disappearance so what we don't know is
what has been found but clearly there is
something there that means the police
now have an area to focus on they think
they have a crime scene
and they are still confident that they
will find katie kenyon
the search
organizer was telling me yesterday he
believed it would be a matter of days
but they are saying publicly it could be
a long time it's a vast area and they
don't know where she is
a grim update there gerald tubb with the
very latest from gisborne forest thanks
very much indeed
the head of nato has said the alliance